in our society we pride ourselves on
planning and being prepared for the
unexpected but a sudden crisis will
often throw curve balls that threaten to
unravel even the best laid plans as was
the case in the summer of 2014 who could
have known that a deadly virus wreaking
havoc in several African countries would
find its way to Atlanta but that's
exactly what happened in 2014 when four
patients infected with the Ebola virus
were brought to Emory University for
treatment steeped in expertise of
infectious diseases Emory's mission to
create preserve teach and apply
knowledge in the service of humanity
would be put to the test between the
months of August and October specialists
would apply every stitch of training
from the transport to treatment to
continuing care the painstaking process
would yield new breakthroughs and Payoh
safety and bio defense today Emory
University leads the National a bola
treatment and education center it's one
facet of a multidisciplinary institution
led by someone who's devoted her life to
the field of Public Health as you'll see
in today's executive profiles
when did becoming a professional
educator become part of your calling I
guess it emerged almost organically I
can tell you that because of the Second
World War both of my parents were unable
to complete their education so I'm the
first one in my family to have a college
degree actually I'm the first one who
have completed high school I ended up
going to the University of Amsterdam
this is a proud moment for your family
it was an incredibly proud moment for my
family for my parents but it also was
one that brought insecurity because I
was entering this world that really
didn't mean much for everybody and there
was some concern of how would I fit in
with the family and I had that as well
because all of a sudden my life was so
different all of that to say that
looking back it wasn't a problem at all
growing up in the Netherlands one of our
activities most every summer was to sit
outside and watch particularly American
students come to Amsterdam and visit
they would play hacky sack and they
would drink too much and they would
smoke too much pot or marijuana whatever
you want to call it and we would go like
they're already so wasted why are they
drinking more or smoking more putting
all that together I believe that I at a
very young age devolved the curiosity
for understanding why people do what
they do how do they find themselves in
situations that are harmful so talk
about your field of study so my social
scientists who ended up in public health
I moved to Atlanta had not been living
here if it wasn't for visiting
scientists at the Centers for Disease
Control did you ever go into an
experiment or to a study and believed
one thing and it turned out to be just
the opposite yes there have been
incredible surprises because as human
beings as you know were so complex so
for example when you see that somebody
is doing harm to him or herself you
would think if you explained what the
harm is people will accept that and then
do something about it and it's quite
interesting to realize that people
understand and accept it and unable to
do something about it so that got me
very interested as a social scientist
and a public health expert to think
about if if we want people to change
their behavior if we want people to do
something different then we first have
to
and what it means to them the Emory
University brand extends across an
entire network B from from the
healthcare organization to the univer to
the undergraduate University to all your
graduate programs what are the things
you try to accomplish in trying to tell
the Emory story to the entire community
we recently completed actually over a
year ago an economic and social impact
study and people are surprised when I
tell them that Emory has 30,000
employees and that our impact on the
state annually for the fiscal year 16
was 9.1 billion so in many ways were
much more than a university and a
healthcare system also at a kind of
place that really prepares people to be
ready for the future and to be problem
solvers and engage in ethical leaders
for the future I have made it my mission
to really provide an integrated Emory
experience and people to think about
Emory as Emily overall and not just as
as a series of segments school colleges
centrum Institute's Emory was in the
headlines about being annexed into the
city of Atlanta what does that do for
the university how does that change the
university and and what advantages you
think that'll have for Emory going
forward we emily has had an Atlanta
advice fund the day it moved to Atlanta
in 1915 and for whatever reason people
at that point in time realized that
Emory University in Atlanta started
better than Emory University in Decatur
so there was a symbolic connection that
there was that wasn't formalized Atlanta
like many other cities the counties went
through a movement of cityhood and the
number of years ago I remember opening
the local newspaper and there was a map
that had Emory become part of one of the
city who it's been only part of Emory so
you realize we can either wait till
somebody claims all our parts of Emory
to become part of a new city to be
formed or we can join a major city which
is a thriving city we think about Emory
is a global leading research University
Atlanta is the gateway to the world so
it makes all the sense a another main
factor for all of this was the
opportunity to get public transportation
to the clifton corridor just talking
about emily we have so many job
opportunities employment opportunities
it's impossible very often
people to get there for all of us to
have public transportation is something
we would strive for now maybe this is
the Dutch in me coming out which has a
quite elaborate public transportation
infrastructure but I'm very excited
about that part is that our nation and
Atlanta is part of this problem is
facing a major opioid crisis is there
one thing that you think is actually
helping the opioid crisis so you think
could take us in the right direction
towards lessening what's going on in the
world and we as tackled the opioid
crisis at numerous levels we have people
in public health and medicine that are
very actively involved in nursing but
also other parts of the university
because it impacts everybody in so many
different ways that impacts society in
many different ways we also have very
focused on awareness we had a town hall
where we invited people from law
enforcement the public health medicine
field as well as a parent who started in
organizations whose daughter had died
from the opioid epidemic so creating
awareness as well so we we deal with the
opioid epidemic at home in the larger
Atlanta area and beyond I also want to
point out that whereas the opioid crisis
certainly is something we need to tackle
today there are lots of preliminary
signs that are indicating that a
methamphetamine epidemic is following
that has happened in the 60s had
happened in the 70s so I would encourage
all of us to do what we're doing in
terms of the opioid epidemic but let's
not forget that it never happens in
isolation and that we have a next wave
of a methamphetamine epidemic following
in its footsteps Emory University is
ranked number one for quality of life
that's according to the Princeton
reviews 2019 best colleges guide and US
News and World Report's ranks Emory
University Hospital the number one
Hospital in Georgia and metro Atlanta